[Music]
inside of you is brought to you by sonos
uh if you've been listening to the
podcast you know how much i love sonos i
have so many devices in my house it goes
on
uh it's a company that i've wanted to i
wanted them to be a sponsor for many
years and finally it happened and i'm so
delighted because i just love this
product and uh i have them all over my
house with sonos you could play a song
in every dif every room of your house a
different song so if you have the kids
and you want the kids who want to listen
to barney or whatever the hell they're
listening to they could listen to that i
could listen to whatever i could listen
to
hendricks upstairs uh you know the wife
i'm not married but if i had one she
could listen to adele
well the kids listening to the smiths
downstairs that's what my kids would be
listening to smith's baby yeah that's
exactly right but uh sonus is pretty
incredible uh the design is awesome
instead of having these giant speakers
and
receivers
get rid of them because all you need is
sonos one sonos speaker sounds better
than all that stuff
um and today we're talking about rome
sonos rome is the ultra portable smart
speaker that allows you to bring the
sonos experience everywhere you go rome
weighs less than a pound and it's
premium durable design makes it perfect
for the home and for on the go when
you're home rome connects to your wi-fi
network and the rest of your sonos
system and then automatically pairs with
your phone on bluetooth when you're on
the go for a seamless experience using
automatic true play tuning rome smartly
adapts to your surroundings and whatever
you're listening to and creates sound
that's astonishingly detailed and
perfectly balanced control roam using
the app apple airplay 2 or your voice
with amazon alexa or google assistant
with sonos you can start with one
speaker and expand your system over time
like i have i have i think nine units
uh nine devices all sonos speakers
connect over wi-fi so you can group
speakers in different rooms and play
music throughout your home i can't tell
you how much i love this enough
try sonos and it's so easy guys you just
go to sonos
s-o-n-o-s
dot com to learn more
that's
sonos.com
to learn more you're listening to inside
of you with michael rosenbaum i am
michael rosenbaum and uh this is ryan
tayze right next to me across from me
cross how you doing i'm all right how
are you i'm doing all right great i'm uh
still recovering from the new year yep
i'm trying to stick to my plan yep
uh i bought i i have to admit i had one
soda
in 16 days
i had one cigarette in 16 days
zero vapes
no cookies very very few snacks
and i've lost 10 pounds
already yes
jesus i know just by a little exercise
and changing your diet you see what
happens
i'm telling you man i don't know um
10 pounds unless there's something else
going on and we lost 10 pounds so
god forbid
but uh very uh i'm just trying to stick
with it man i'm trying people always
like by the 11th or by the end of the
month you'll be off at just like
everybody else new year's resolutions
they go out the window by the end of
january i'm like [ __ ] off i'm going to
continue this
we got all year to do it
i know that's the hard part i got a year
to freaking do it hey guys thanks for
listening if you are digging the podcast
if you're here for angie harmon or if
you like you know listening to all these
other people that have come on the
podcast
i'd love you to just do this to
subscribe and write a review if you
write a review whether you're on spotify
or apple it helps tremendously helps the
show so much and follow us on our
handles ryan with our handles uh at
inside of you pod on twitter inside of
your podcast instagram and face
that's correct that's correct so you
know
i get a lot of letters and people really
enjoy the show so i hope uh i hope that
you are enjoying it i hope you're having
a good week if you're driving to work or
if you're at home
shut the door
take an hour off
hang out with me and ryan for a bit and
uh our guest
i think that would be nice
i also want you to know that uh my band
sunspin has a concert virtual you can
come see us virtually so you have to
leave the house january 29th two shows 2
p.m and 6 p.m
i'd really love some of you to come that
haven't seen the show please come
support the band
you can get tickets by going to
sunspin.com or
stageit.com and type in sunspin great
prizes zooms we're giving away like
lunch boxes uh sunspin lunchboxes with
tons of stuff
um also i want to say thank all my
patrons out there if you want to join
patreon and give back to the podcast
there's a lot of perks and prizes and
things that we do
and it really helps the podcast so thank
you for joining a lot of people have
been joining patreon lately uh just go
to patreon p-a-t-r-e-o-n dot com slash
inside of you and join i'll write you a
message right after thanking you
and um
also if you need any merch where do they
go ryan they go to the the merch store
inside of you online store that one and
there's tons of tumblers inside of you
there's small the lunch boxes there's i
have small little scripts signed by me
anyway lots of great stuff so go to the
inside of your online store limited
supply and uh i just want to again thank
everybody for for tuning in happy new
year i hope you're enjoying we got some
great guests coming up we've had some
great guests already this year tom
willing jensen ackles brandon routh
um
it's been great it's been great and i
hope you guys continue to support the
podcast even if you don't like the
guests maybe you just like finding out
something about the guest that you
didn't know you know what i think it's
time i think we get into uh she's a
lovely woman she's honestly a fantastic
human being i've known her for a while
she's got a lot to talk about and i
really uh i really enjoyed her so let's
get inside of angie harmon it's my point
of view
you're listening to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
angie harmon i mean i might as well have
had
robert de niro on the podcast
you are you are as amazing and the most
awesome woman i probably have ever met
it couldn't have been more difficult to
get you on this podcast
i'm so sorry wait no okay i wait it's
good
this is good a lot of people wanted you
on this podcast they're like when's
angie harmon coming on yes
oh thank you
what's that
what's that giant um
cotton ball above your head
let's break my hat
it's a fantastic hat i think you look
fantastic it's like it's my feather
chandelier as every proper southern
woman has in her red lacquered office my
god that's a good office you have a good
office you're very are you meticulously
like neat
oh god i try to be and no if you could
actually see
what this room looks like and why i'm
sweating
why are you sweating
well first of all
because i get i don't know why i i
it's just it never works out like i had
to run across town over here then i had
to run across down over there then i had
to run back over here and i was upstairs
like trying to put my face on and that
was a disaster and then i came
downstairs and then my computer wouldn't
work and then i was in the kitchen and
you're like no no phone oh my computer
and i was like oh god
but here we are yesterday
folks uh angie emailed me 30 minutes
before and said you're going to kill me
but i have to pick up my daughter or
something i don't remember what it was
but yes that's exactly what it was are
you do you feel like you're a sort of a
frantic like always everything's last
minute and you're you know you just
you've just been like some people like
personalities are like that i i get like
that like where i have so much going on
that i forget things i don't write them
down i'm in and out the door and i'm
just and it's just is it you do that and
it's it's never a clean exit like you
get out the door you get in the car you
realize you've forgotten three things
you gotta go back in never a clean exit
and yes and i really try
to be organized and unless somebody
hands me a call sheet every morning of
like the dry cleaners and the laundry
and the grocery store and this i've been
out of vanilla creamer for four days i
mean my coffee has literally sucked
every morning because i don't have my
vanilla creamer
do you have structure in your life do
you feel like you need structure in your
life like when you're on
risoli and isles or when you're on law
and order you have like a a you know a
plan you this is your day and you need
that do you go crazy if you're if you
don't have that
i mean
i definitely need that i would love to
have that
um
but i can't pay anybody enough to do
that for me
so i just kind of wing it all the way
you know what it's like this is funny a
friend of mine said this the other day
so do you remember the movie better off
dead of course i remember better off
dead
i knew you would i knew you were coming
okay so listen so remember when he's at
the top of the mountain and he has no
idea how to ski
his friend's like okay look you're going
to go down this
real fast
and if something gets in your way just
turn
that's kind of how i go through every
day
right now at this point in my life you
need somebody to tell you what to do and
you're going to do it
correct just give me the call sheet this
is what we do from this time and this is
what we do from this time and somebody
needs to do my makeup and hair of course
and then you know i need my wardrobe
picked out and i'm sad i'm golden you
don't have a full-time assistant you are
i mean come on you have to i mean
how do you not
and i don't have nannies and i don't
have any of that crap like it is just me
well how old are the kids now
well
fan is
17 and a senior and then avery is 16 and
a sophomore and emery is 12
and in seventh grade
so it's not like i really need a nanny
you know per se
but i mean the girls are they're so epic
they are just the most legendary human
beings that you have ever met in your
entire life really you're not dealing
with any problems as they're in high
school now because i there was always
issues in my family and most people's
families you don't have to deal with you
know bad behavior unsatisfactory i
always had on my report cards use
used for unsatisfactory
michael's behavior is unsatisfactory
used we had used and s's satisfactory
unsatisfactory
my parents had meetings all the time and
there's a lot of gray in between there
you know there's a lot i think there was
another letter for the gray area like an
n yeah like
undecided
i don't know remember what it was so i
mean
how do you do that how do you work and
like keep three kids going and i haven't
i haven't worked since rizzoli i mean it
just i haven't
i told the girls that i would never
leave them again the way that i had to
do with that and that i've kept my
promise
really
wow yeah
yeah cause i was i mean when i started
rosalie isles emery was in diapers and
when i
you know got back she was seven
so wow
is there a lot of is there a lot of
guilt in that like even though you have
to work and make a living do you feel
like gosh i'm not there for them
yeah i did for a while um
you know it's it's
and i would fly back and forth across
the country as much as i could and
you know obviously i was they were with
me for the summers i mean in los angeles
they have a great sort of
you know multi-cultural they have like
you know their charlotte and then they
have their la and
and um but yeah there's definitely a ton
of guilt that was attached with that now
have i made up for it in spain yes
because i'm an awesome mom
and
literally i mean like i was i was
telling finn lady
you of all people you're gonna love this
so i was telling finley my 17 year old
um
like my 16 year old went to the beach
with her boyfriend this weekend and
you know my 12 year old like spent the
night out at her friends all this past
weekend it was a long weekend as you
know
so i kind of got a front row seat with
finley and you know
watching just
who she is and how she handles herself
and how she handles her friends and how
she handles her boyfriend who i adore
who is very darling and um
it was just really really wonderful and
so i told her that i sent her
a text i actually said
hey
i was talking to my therapist this
morning
i just wanted you to know that this is
what i said and you know how awesome you
are and how proud of you i am and you
know if you were my age i would totally
want to hang out
and i would want i would seek your
counsel if i had a problem like i would
look to you for advice that's how highly
i think of you and so and finley wrote
back
oh mommy that's so sweet and then she
wrote
girl g-u-r-l
you know we be bffs but i know we
getting a lot of [ __ ] together
what your year old daughter said this to
you
17.
there's a difference
we would get in [ __ ] together
oh yeah
and i mean like that makes me so happy
because
she
she's got a great sense of humor she
totally i mean
i'm kind of like a high strung high
stakes type of person and you know my
girls know like if you can laugh
life is going to be a lot easier and so
you know i mean
we've laughed at a funeral before i mean
we just
they go through so much as kids as
teenagers
and i'm just like girls come on and so
we do that like we we use humor in a lot
of things and
and i just answered her with yeah and
that's not any of that misdemeanor stuff
that's two to five right there
but don't you have boundaries because
you know my parents my parents were the
extremes on the other side where they
were extremely strict i was always
grounded i couldn't confide in them i
couldn't trust them i didn't trust them
i didn't you know
i just really didn't like them very much
growing up and you seem to have this
great relationship with your kids do you
think there's ever a line that's crossed
like i don't want to know this
information this is too much information
or they feel comfortable like oh i'm
gonna drink we're gonna go drink at the
harman house
okay see and that's a lot of balancing
out because
you know here's the thing it's like we
both know what we were doing at their
age
you know um and
yes i absolutely have that relationship
with my daughters it's like i want to
know where you are i want to know what
you're doing are you drinking what's
happening i want to know whose card
they're in
and you know before it was kind of just
like oh my god i don't want to know any
of this
but now you know they've they've gotten
to be
super responsible
um
and it was kind of so i
everyone's gonna think i'm such a crappy
parent now but i'll put you this way all
i could remember was like remember those
kids in high school that their parents
were so strict they couldn't do anything
and they went to college and they went
berserk
and like yeah you never ended well
well now imagine if you're a girl
so it never ended well
and you know so with my girls we just we
have open lines of communication they
know what the rules are they know what
the boundaries are and we have many of
them
you know and they know that this isn't
like the party house because
it's just not i mean that's just not
what i'm into i mean there are so many
horribly dangerous things that can
happen
to them just on a daily basis outside of
you know right now we're gonna have a
you know big party at the harmon house
so but i do appreciate
the relationship that we have because
there is an honesty there
that i did not have you know with my
parents neither did you and i think
had i i just think it would have been
different had i been able to know that
you know
if something had happened and i needed
to call my parents that i wouldn't get
in trouble i wouldn't be judged i
wouldn't be grounded i wouldn't be in
that stuff and that's you know the girls
they know that
inside of you is brought to you by helix
sleep uh i'd say sleep is probably the
number one thing you can do for your
body for the most part wouldn't you say
i think if you don't get a good night's
sleep you're effed
because
i mean how many hours in your lifetime
do you sleep more hours than you're
awake
isn't it probably it's a pretty large
percentage of your life it's a large
percentage
it is and the bed you choose is huge
because you wake up you don't want to
have back eggs like me you don't want to
have fatigue you didn't sleep so picking
out the the best mattress for you is
important and you know today it's not
easy to sleep you get the politics you
got pandemics your love life you know uh
any other drama that you can think of
but uh it's hard to sleep helix sleep
has a quiz that takes just two minutes
to complete i can do it i have add i
took it it's so easy it matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you why would you
buy a mattress made from someone else
with helix you're getting a mattress
that you know will be perfect for the
way you sleep everybody's unique and
helix knows that
so they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have soft
medium and firm mattresses mattresses
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot and even a helix plus mattress for
plus size sleepers yep i took the helix
quiz i was matched to a medium mattress
it's like porridge you know medium was
just right for me and uh you know it's
just uh it's it's an incredibly
comfortable bed and you you all should
try it i have friends that have a helix
bed bryce bryce my producer has a helix
pad and loves it he's been he's had one
for about a year and a half or so nice
and really digs it and i'm like well
they're a sponsor now he's like wow
great because i like them uh it's been
awesome getting messages from so many of
you
who also found the helix mattress of
your dreams so if you're looking for a
mattress just take the quiz order the
mattress that you're matched to and the
mattress comes right to your door
shipped for free
that's right ship for free you don't
need to go to a mattress store ever
again thank god
just go to helix h-e-l-i-x sleep.com
inside by the way uh it was the best
overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq and
wired magazine helix is for real uh so
helix sleep.com slash inside take their
two minute sleep quiz and they'll match
you to a customized mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your life you
got a 10-year warranty to try this out
for a hundred nights wait oh sorry and
they have a 10 year warranty and you get
to try it out for 100 nights risk free
helix is also offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helixsleep.com
inside that's
slash inside for up to 200 off and two
free pillows inside of you is brought to
you by better help boy uh i'll tell you
if it's one sponsor that i could really
relate to and uh not that i don't relate
to all the others i do but better help
online therapy
uh i'll tell you it's changing lives
it's helping people all across the world
so many of my friends are doing it using
it ryan you use betterhelp how's your
therapy going it's going very well yeah
i feel like you got a good therapist now
and you're uh you're happy i yeah i am i
do uh yeah it's great and you use it uh
at least every month yeah no uh once a
week once a week once a week i have a
video chat session and you know the uh
yeah the the text chat is always open so
if there's any any issues
or uh someone's got a lesson for you
then yeah it's great so you just text
them
you know people think you should wait
until things are are unbearable to go to
therapy
and that's co that couldn't be further
from the truth therapy is a tool to
utilize before things get worse and it
can help you avoid those lows
sometimes we just wait till everything's
just hit the fan and then we go i need
therapy
if you feel like you're starting to lose
a little control if you feel like you're
starting to
feel that depression anxiety
you just need someone else to talk to
someone objectively
better help online therapy folks many
people think therapy is for so-called
crazy people
but therapy doesn't mean something's
wrong with you it means you recognize
that all humans have emotions and we
need to learn to control them
not avoid them and we've been taught
that mental health shouldn't be a part
of normal life
uh but that's wrong we take care of our
bodies with the gym
the doctor and nutrition we should be
focusing on our minds just as much and i
i
wholeheartedly agree uh betterhelp has
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to i like to see them so does ryan yeah
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours give it a
try and see why over 2 million people
have used better help online therapy
inside your listeners get 10 percent off
by going to
com betterhelp.com inside that's better
help b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash inside do yourselves a
favor
get some help
inside of you is brought to you by home
medics massager
uh homedics makes some great product uh
i've got back issues i feel like i'm
getting i feel older than i should feel
and uh you know they sent me this
massage chair it's like a massage chair
you could actually lie down you can
massage you could sit up and it's it's
strong it's not one of these weak things
that you get at like a target
i'm not going to say the name but
they sent me some product and i was
really impressed i had so much comfort
in uh using their product
uh you gotta try homedics guys they've
got a whole line of massage products
from a massage gun with built-in hot and
cold technology to a massage cushion
that lets you lie down or sit up
depending on your therapeutic needs see
they also have a three-in-one foot
massager with vibrations so powerful it
loosens the muscles in your legs and
lower back
i just got that and i'm gonna try it i
haven't tried that one because i just
got it but i'm gonna try and you should
try it with me by the way they have an a
plus better business bureau rating
really if you can believe that
i mean i like to look at that stuff i
like to see those things a plus yeah
that's pretty damn good i never got an a
plus no i've never had a c plus
look whether you're dealing with chronic
pain like me or just looking to help
your muscles recover from a workout
we've got good news right now if you go
to homedics that's h-o-m-e-d-i-c-s
dot com slash inside and use the promo
code inside
you'll receive a free portable phone
sanitizer when you buy a hundred dollars
or more in massage products
that's a sixty dollar value that's h o m
e d i c s dot com slash inside and use
the promo code inside for your free
portable phone sanitizer with a hundred
dollar massager purchase uh homedics
they make some great product and you
should check them out
now
all right so go back so let's go back to
little harmon let's go back to little
angie so what was it like growing up
like in in texas and
i mean what were you doing as a kid were
you a good kid were but you said you
didn't really you couldn't confide in
your folks what was that like growing up
well you first
well i tell you it was it was a lot of
dysfunction i i don't think my parents
really sort of carried exactly where i
was i had surrogate uh families like my
friends families were became my families
i'd stay at their house a lot they'd
like does your mom know you're here i'm
like she don't care
oh michael well no no i mean
my mom didn't i don't think she of
course she cared it was just it was kind
of like my brother told me he was like
you know
it was kind of like you didn't exist
like like not exist but you'd like no
one paid attention to you my brother
said this to me
not long ago when i and i go wow you saw
that too it was the first time somebody
had acknowledged it it was like yeah you
just kind of went by and they're like oh
and they just didn't pay attention to
you and
what were your parents like i mean did
they pay attention to you um
well
no i mean not in the way that you want
them to
you know what i mean like like we wanted
but i will tell you this i have a lot of
kids
that stay at my house like i am a
surrogate yeah mom to a lot
to a lot of kids and i love that i love
that that's my role i love that they put
me in that position and it's not
necessarily because
you know their whole life is so terrible
i mean my whole life you know was
terrible and that's really all i want to
you know get into really growing up
growing up was growing up was horrible
horrible
like horrible
i mean statistically speaking i should
be
hooking in some trailer park like
addicted to math like that's you know
statistically speaking wow that's where
i should be
but i just decided i don't know that's
not very pretty
well how do you get out of that though
you don't have to talk about that per se
but like like what how did you get out
of that then because i got out of it by
you know i remember i did a play in high
school and somebody said acknowledged me
for the first time in my life like oh
you're funny and that's all i needed
some attention yeah and you and i think
are a lot of liking that thing we we
love attention and we're outgoing and
fun and we also drain the [ __ ] out of
ourselves probably where we're exhausted
after going to a party because
everybody's like oh my god angie's so
delightful and vivacious and just full
of life and and then you get home you're
like oh my god i'm going to die
kinda
but i'll tell you i mean it took me a
long it took me a long time to
to get to
to appreciate
not only what i didn't have but what i
also have now because at the end of the
day michael i mean it taught us to be
who we are
and you know right now
i'm i'm really
you know kind of fascinated and enjoying
who i am i mean it was it was so hard
for so long
i mean let's not forget like while i was
shooting rizzoli i was going through a
divorce you know there was all kinds of
problems there my best friend killed
himself that you know it was just and
all it was was just like you know we had
like a couple of just really horrible
people on that set that were always just
like
creating problems so it was like i would
go to work and there would just be so
many problems and so many horrible
things to deal with and then i would fly
home and then there would be so many
problems and so many horrible things to
do it just how did you not implode did
you implode oh i did i did and how so
how did you do that because you go to
therapy like i do how did you how did
you navigate how did you what were the
things you noticed about yourself that
you didn't like during that period of
time oh gosh i i mean i was i had
zero patience i was so depressed
um
you know when
it just it was like it was like this
little box just kept getting smaller and
smaller and smaller and to be honest i
you know i really feel like being like
jane rosoli you know saved my life in a
very profound way
because i could get to work and just
angie would just disappear
and then jane would take over which i
know sounds so wackadoo but that's just
what happened yeah you know
i mean i i think it's a really wonderful
thing when you have a character
i was lucky enough you know at the end
there to be with
you know some very nurturing like when
jan nash came on board that was the most
nurturing most wonderful human being
and i mean our entire like cast and crew
were like you know
beaten children
that were cowering in the corner and
she's just you know i call her
the janda because she's like a big panda
bear and she's just so loving and kind
and sweet and supportive and
collaborative and all of those things
and as we know you know
certain there are a lot of people in our
business that aren't like that well who
who like you don't have to say who but
like what caused such a dysfunctional
family within the this the filming of
brazilian isles like where the crew
would cower on a corner that's that's
dramatic that's well we have i mean we
had a real like there was a person that
was in charge that was really really
dysfunctional
and then i think um it was i think it
was just jealousy
like i think that's just all it boils
down to
which at the end of the day it's you
know
that's their problem you know and and
when you're people like us and hey and
this isn't this great we're so blessed
we get to pretend for a living and oh my
gosh and my character always wins and
i'm super tough and look at my gun and
yeah yeah yeah and
like how
like where is the problem in that i
don't know i think i don't know i just
think some people just can't
they just can't see what they have and
so they're never there's always this
hole that they're trying to fill and it
never gets full well they always say
that if you're not
happy before you become really
successful or famous
you're never going to be happy
like in terms of what you have to really
work on in other words money and fame
isn't going to make you happy
not at all not at all
i mean and i will say
um
you know i i think there are definitely
people that become i mean hello reality
shows there are definitely people that
become actors not because they love
acting
like i became an actor because i love it
you know i wanted to go to juilliard i
couldn't even like we had zero money
there was no chance i was going i didn't
even take an sat or an act which is what
like my girls were doing now i'm like
i don't know i didn't really do this
where's the nanny
yeah
like the nanny's just going to be
brilliant you know
anyway
okay
but like
i think that some people get into our
business because they just want to be
famous and that's not
fulfilling
you know what i mean like if you become
an actor just because you want to be
famous then you're just kind of dialing
it in for all of the fun part
and then you show up when when it's just
i don't know i've seen so many people
like that and it's it's sad really
because we are
truly some of the luckiest people on the
planet i mean we get paid to pretend i
know
and it's depressed it is by the way i
mean you
i mean how old were you when you started
modeling
oh my
we have a picture of me in a car seat
like like in like the kmart like
newspaper thing
and you're
who was it who was your mom very
influential in that she wanted you to be
a model
she was actually um i do often sorry
this keeps um
yeah i i do really really feel like it
was god's divine hand in my life
um because yeah i mean she was the one
that entered me into the 17 cover model
contest and to be fair you know it's not
like i was going to get a car i mean we
didn't have any money i went to like the
wealthiest school
in
dallas and you know and so
to be fair i won
the cover contest so i won a car so
that's how i got one
i mean i just see god's hands in so many
things in my life you know and
and i don't know i think that's why my
faith is so strong and i think
you know it's just kind of um
i don't know it's just he's just where
it's at no i mean so you go to church
we've had this conversation before yeah
we have you go to church every sunday
um i do but because of the virus we
can't go so i watch it oh and you you
know what you should watch bishop td
jakes you would love him
bishop
td jakes he's in the potter's house
in dallas and like i just get on there
and i mean
i love that man so much he's a good
speaker he speaks from the heart
oh yeah but he's so awesome and he
doesn't
preach at you he preaches to you and you
can tell i mean like this man he's a
very very wise man
and he just he's in our business like he
works with tyler perry a ton i'm a jew
does it matter can i still listen to him
that's good that's good to know
you could have said oh
you're a jew
yeah that's not gonna work out
first of all what jackass says yeah
exactly but you know there are people
that say that you know well oh yeah
bishops bishop he's not right for you
michael rosen
but then you know what then i know i
think that you got to check him out on
your own and one of my favorite things
it's like he'll say something like super
profound and he'll be it then he'll go
y'all will hear what i'm saying to you
let me come over here and he'll go over
to that side and he's like on a you know
a state i mean i'll check it out
yeah he's awesome he really is hey how
hard was it uh becoming such a famous
model
and you know being at the top you know
the top really i mean you were doing all
the huge magazines in the future you
were one of the big models of all time
and
i have to think that it i mean it looks
so glamorous and fun but it probably
wasn't all the time was it
well first of all i have to say i do not
consider myself a success as a model
me you know i consider like linda
christie naomi and cindy and claudia and
stephanie that was the success but you
were a big model
i was with them like in the same step as
them but i was never that tear in my
opinion well you don't have to compare
yourself but
right you don't have to compare yourself
to them but you could say i had a lot of
success in modeling
okay yeah that's a good point okay yes
correct i had a lot of success as as
modeling and to be honest
i wish
i would have oh god don't
kill me or judge me i was one of those
girls that was pretty but didn't know
she was pretty no but that's the best
that's the best kind
oh you sweet thing like i look back at
those things now
and i look at finley and you know my
daughters and i'm like oh my god y'all
are so stunning and i look at those you
know people send me stuff on social
media all the time and i look at the
shoots that i did and the places that i
mean like
i i was on the great wall of china with
valentino there you go
right i mean you can't make that up
that's amazing i was on the concord with
kate moss and sting and i mean all of
that stuff what i just
yeah that's a power sting how was sting
i'll tell you when i met him because i i
mean oh my god how much do you love that
guy when i met him it was in like some
nightclub
and he clearly was not interested in
like meeting you know
fangirling models or whatever and i
totally respected that but it was just
like
what you know because one of my friends
was like his biggest fan he's like why
get out of here and then like and i'm
just like oh
and then that was kind of it
which it's fine but you know you you
expect him to be like some profound like
you know
so you weren't stung you weren't stung
i was not stuck yeah because i didn't
expect him to be like us
right right right but flying like flying
on the concord i mean were these great
experiences because i always hear a lot
of stuff about
modeling and your agents are always like
oh um katie you need to lose 10 pounds
or you need to do this and it's it's
very hard and it could be and a lot of
people go through a lot of [ __ ] and i'm
just wondering if you ever had to go
through that stuff
i never heard any of that kind of stuff
but i think that's because that was just
how i was naturally
um
but you know yeah we i definitely i had
a girlfriend that died um of an eating
disorder i had
you know um
you know yeah i mean but i think
i don't know i just i just wish like
when i look back on my life
i wish i would have appreciated it more
when i was in it
at all don't we all it's like you look
at these moments in these pictures and
you're like i don't remember having
as great of a time as
i remember maybe because i wasn't as
present my problem is i'm not as present
it's hard for me to be present i'm
always
my mind just is going a million miles an
hour are you able to do that now and
experience things and kind of go i'm
blessed i'm grateful look at this moment
take it in are you able to do that more
well yeah cause now i'm medicated
are you really
absolutely are you kidding i'm a single
mom with three daughters yeah
there's an anti-anxiety in there
somewhere uh yes by the way i you know i
take an anti-anxiety thing too
yeah and i just started necessarily i
mean it's just
especially and you know i'm kind of on
like the tail end of the things that you
know you know it's like
it's just all of and i and i had this
conversation with finley actually i said
you know it can't be easy
being the oldest
it cannot be easy being the first one to
go through all of this stuff you know
because as she goes through it i go
through it and
you know i have only my experience to go
off of
and only my fears for her and
you know it's not like i had like the
healthiest childhood so
i'm constantly trying to you know
not do
what i know
but allow
that super
fierce loyal
um passionate
person that i am
to be
but balance you know i mean it's tough
it is tough by the way how is it you
need to come spend a week here in
charlotte with us
you would love it i would love it i love
kids i love you i mean i think it'd be a
hilarious
nothing else it would be hilarious it
would be a fun time
and then afterwards would i leave saying
i'm i'm glad i don't have any kids i'm
glad you t yeah
that's the thing though is that now that
they're teenagers
you know it's it's a different way of
communicating it's you know you can be
sarcastic you can be funny you can you
know
and
i'm not going to pretend like i never
curse i never do i do all the time
every day i wake up and i'm like i'm not
going to curse today i'm not going to
curse you know and then who knows what
happens and
just this barrage of you know naughty
words
you know what you should do is it's it's
kind of fun now i hang out with a couple
of a couple of my friends are mormons uh
john heater from napoleon dynamite he
was napoleon dynamite name drop but uh
he he does this thing where he doesn't
really swear so he'll be he'll say
that's effing ridiculous
so i say f in or if i go
ah what a instead of what a dick what a
d
and it's just so stupid it's funny and
it makes me want to do that more than
swear
yes i swear the other day
i did something and
and emory my youngest is was in the car
that's when oh f-bomb
see that's funnier than the actual word
it is
inside of you is brought to you by geico
geico makes life easy ryan it really
does how so well you know whether you
rent your home you own your home we've
talked about this
you know that's the biggest hurdle is
paying your mortgage and you have but
you have all these other payments your
auto policy and your
so what if i told you geico has this
bundling policy so you bundle your
homeowners or renters insurance along
with your auto policy it's so easy
why don't you want to make your life
easy you do want to make it easy
geico easy and the thing you do
is you just go to geico.com you get a
quote and you see how much you can save
it's geico easy go visit geico.com and
save today that's geico.com inside of
you is brought to you by sonos if you've
been listening to the podcast you know
how much i love sonos i have so many
devices in my house i it goes on
uh it's a company that i've wanted to
i wanted them to be a sponsor for many
years and finally it happened and i'm so
delighted because i just love this
product and uh i have them all over my
house with sonos you could play a song
in every dif every room of your house a
different song so if you have the kids
and you want the kids who want to listen
to barney or whatever the hell they're
listening to they could listen to that
um i could listen to whatever i could
listen to
uh hendrix upstairs uh you know the wife
i'm not married but if i had one she
could listen to adele
what the kids listening to the smiths
downstairs that's what my kids would be
listening to smith's baby yeah that's
exactly right but uh sonus is pretty
incredible uh the design is awesome
instead of having these giant speakers
and uh
receivers get rid of them because all
you need is sonos one zone of speaker
sounds better than all that stuff
um and today we're talking about rome
sonos rome is the ultra portable smart
speaker that allows you to bring the
sonos experience everywhere you go rome
weighs less than a pound and it's
premium durable design makes it perfect
for the home and for on the go when
you're home rome connects to your wi-fi
network and the rest of your sonos
system and then automatically pairs with
your phone on bluetooth when you're on
the go for a seamless experience using
automatic true play tuning roam smartly
adapts to your surroundings and whatever
you're listening to and creates sound
that's astonishingly detailed and
perfectly balanced control roam using
the app apple airplay 2 or your voice
with amazon alexa or google assistant
with sonos you can start with one
speaker and expand your system over time
like i have i have i think nine units
uh nine devices all sonos speakers
connect over wi-fi so you can group
speakers in different rooms and play
music throughout your home i can't tell
you how much i love this enough
try sonos and it's so easy guys you just
go to sonos s-o-n-o-s
dot com to learn more that's sonos.com
to learn more
did david hasselhoff really find you on
a plane and discover you and that's how
your acting career started is that
really true because you read [ __ ] and
you're right
that is really now i i have this picture
of him sitting in seat 3d
and
he was on one of those planet hollywood
planes
he was
even better
and you were on the plane
yep and he
came up to you tell me the story
and he um he came up to me and he was
like i have this show
and
you would be perfect for it and i wasn't
even an actor
you know i was a model you hadn't
studied acting you hadn't studied or you
hadn't done anything
nothing wow nothing and um
i mean like i did you know like drama my
senior year in high school
and you know everybody said i was good
at it and i made some people cry and i
was like okay whatever um
and so
yeah he did and i was like oh that's
very nice thank you very much i mean i
didn't want to be rude i was like i'm
actually not an actor and he was like
well you should be and you know let me
send you this stuff i was like oh no no
it's okay no sorry whatever
and then um the people that i was with
on the um plane one of them went in
on an audition for the show that he was
talking about and he was like you were
with that girl
and
she was like yes and and
get her in here can you bring her in
here and i went in and
i got it
you read you read a scene with
david i think
yes yes i did and it was enough
it was enough he looked at you did he
tell you right then this is yours
were you scared out of your socks
you had never acted before now you're
going to be on baywatch nights what the
what were you how much preparation did
you do and how
how did you approach this
i mean
i just went in there and
it was very jimmy stewart i just knew my
lines i didn't bump into the furniture
and they liked it i guess
but you know what you'll love this story
oh my god you're gonna love this all
right and i've never told this story
before okay good are you ready yes okay
you are
there you go all right okay so when i
was a model
um
and you know going to clubs and bars and
all that stuff and it was so awesome and
there were so many creative and talented
gifted people gifted
and one of the people that i knew
was this i mean
devastatingly handsome african-american
gentleman and he was the drummer
for eric clapton wow and
somehow we were all together one night
and you know all of us were singing and
all that kind of stuff and he was like
you need to sing
and i was like oh thanks for so sweet he
was no angie i'm serious like you need
to sing he was like you should come you
should go audition for eric
and i was like uh
okay
and he set up a time and he set up the
studio and all that and i didn't go
uh-huh what
and i didn't go because i was scared and
i was you know like oh my god i just i
didn't go
so i run into him about probably about a
month later
and i've got some more experience under
my belt and i'm kind of like oh okay and
i walked up to him you know like a
nonchalant lackadaisical young stupid
person does and i was like hey you know
you know what i'm ready to do that can
you can you reschedule it and he just
looks when he was like no
that ship has sailed
and i mean
when i said like oh my god i'm breaking
out just sweats
i was so embarrassed oh my god my hands
are shaking i was so mortified i was
just
and you know what he said
he looked at me and he goes you see you
know that feeling that you're feeling
right now
and i went yes and he goes don't ever
feel it again
and i never have
in other words you took the bull by the
horns you you you
never missed an opportunity again when
you had it
never
wow
how about that he called you out on your
[ __ ] and it changed you yeah
totally if he wouldn't have done that
that day you think you'd have been doing
the same [ __ ]
probably i mean like i said i think
god's had a really big hand in my path
but i mean can you beli how
transformative like what an incred i've
never seen him since i don't remember
his name i would only know his face he
had the most handsome face he had like
the whitest most perfect teeth he was so
beautiful
and like
i mean
you know that feeling you're feeling
right now
never feel it again you know that's on
the same line i mean it's not the exact
same thing but they always say you don't
change yourself a lot of times until you
hit rock bottom or until some your
actions cause some kind of reaction that
is devastating or you don't like about
yourself that forces you to sort of make
a difference make a change in your life
and that one statement that he shot at
you
kind of made you go whoa what the [ __ ]
am i doing
that's crazy that's amazing next time
you meet him you should tell him uh wow
you really helped me along my career
i know i mean but who knows if i'm never
going to see me he was english and
that's all i know
you know that feeling you're having
right now don't ever feel it again never
feel it never effing feel it again
i'm like what was that it was like a
weird michael kane something what was i
doing my engineer ryan just looked at me
like what are you doing
i don't know
um you know but you you look at yourself
after doing baywatch nights and then you
start doing stuff
but then you look at your career you
look at your acting
nominated for all these sag awards for
law and order
you know resilient aisles like you
really just like you there had to be
work
you had to put in a [ __ ] ton of work
what it what are you doing
oh another story to pick this up oh look
at that she's holding an award what is
that phallic-like award
right this is my people's choice award
did you win for uh rizzoli
i did yes congratulations how does that
how did that feel when you won an award
you wanna know that story that one was
terrible
so
so it was
i can't believe you're getting me to
tell all this i love it this is what
it's about
i know but like you know how private i
am and now you [ __ ] you got me
telling everything this is fun this is
what people want to hear they're going
to love you even more for like letting
go a little bit this is great
well you're going to love this so it was
the people's choice awards
and um it was the first day of my
mediation in my divorce so i was here in
charlotte and um
i started like getting you know all
these texts like
congratulations congratulations
congratulations and you know
my best friend
monica calls me and she's like
you won
and i'm like
oh what
what are you ever a few curse words in
there i was like no i do i'm on the
phone with my lawyer leave me alone
she calls me back and she's like listen
to me you won you won your category and
i'm like
i no i didn't what's your face one and
then and i was like no i don't have time
for this i gotta go i'm talking about
some serious crap here
you know hang up i mean and when i tell
you like my divorce was it was
devastating i mean i walked around with
my bible i mean it was you know
and so
she calls me back she goes
listen you dumbass
go to the website
and pull up your effing category and
look at your effing picture because
there is an effing banner that says
winner across your effing face
for people's choice awards
i didn't even get to go i wasn't even
there i didn't even get to do a speech i
didn't get to do anything oh my god but
that had to feel good during all that
[ __ ] that you're dealing with to have a
little acknowledgement to have a little
something like that that's nice look at
you
that's fantastic now if one of the kids
broke that how would you respond
well i mean i would
kill them of course and i would go to
prison
what what kind of uh
studying did you do by the way to
prepare for these roles to to take it to
the next step
well for rosalie that was a blast
because i went to boston
and hung out with all of the homicide
detectives and
if i weren't an actor then i would be a
homicide detective i mean it's just it's
like the highest stakes you know
puzzle solving there's justice involved
you help people you bring closure you
kill the mfr that did whatever he did i
mean like
awesome
oh my god i love it and we had
we had one where
i mean i have to be honest i mean it was
like i was there for like three or four
days before anything happened and i
called the detective that i was working
with i was like come on i mean like i
gotta go in 48 hours like somebody's got
to kill somebody somewhere this is
boston i mean from what i understand it
happens a bit here
and yeah
and he was like harmon i swear to god he
is i don't think i've ever had anyone so
anxious for murder
just like i'm not trying to be
mean-spirited but like i don't have a
lot of time here like i gotta go
so shirt up like 215 sirens and i call
him i'm like is that one and he's like
yeah it's one i'm coming to pick you up
all right so you're on a what do they
call it a drive what is it a
ride along ride along a ride along yeah
but it was awesome so
we went we got into this
well i'll tell you about the there were
two the second one we were outside of
the courthouse and this man had gone
into court
with these four people
and they were fighting over something i
can't remember what
well when we found when we got to him
and and he he was still in his car with
his foot on the brake and he had a
gunshot wound to the neck and he just
bled out all over the place wait did you
see this
oh yeah you saw him bleed out
no no we i mean
he was dead when we got there but you
saw him dead
oh yeah what was that like seeing a dead
person weird question
i i know weird weird answer i loved it i
mean i loved it you loved seeing someone
dead
but that doesn't sound right
i mean
it's not that i look i was like yay he's
dead it's not like that right right i
was like oh my god how are we going to
figure this out what are we going to do
this is amazing
you know and oh my god it was crazy all
the stuff that they had to do because
they couldn't move the car was out here
in public so they had to tarp it
and then his foot was on the brake so
they really couldn't move it so they had
to wait to get a warrant they had i mean
to do all of the stuff just to get
him still in the car
in
uh back to the station and in the garage
and even then they couldn't take him out
and so we had because they had to like
process the scene and the car was the
scene so like we've got doors open we're
walking all around like we're not
touching anything like it was it was
unbelievable and then they would look at
me like angie what do you think and i'll
be like this is incredible they're like
no like what do you think happened
i mean they let me just be just be
involved they were so great i love
boston pd
did you have a lot of good answers were
they surprised by some kind of some some
of your responses
i don't think so i think because i was
just so in awe of them i mean it was
like standing there with you know batman
and robin and wonder woman and you know
aquaman and all them i was just like
what okay
whatever you're saying i mean they were
just
so cool to me
and then we went upstairs and they had
caught
the people that did it and it was
a god like a kid a kid like 20s right
his mother
his girlfriend and a friend
so he they put it together and
when they had him in four separate rooms
and the detectives were going back and
forth and they literally had like the
one hot head and the one calm guy
i mean i was just like oh my god this is
the coolest thing i've ever seen
like it was it was just incredible and
the one hot head guy he was like we
gotta get this [ __ ] and that and
all that kind of stuff and the other guy
was like if you go in there and make him
take a powder test they're going to be
able to take it from you and we've got
nothing you've got to calm down you've
got to get in there and convince him to
like it was incredible wow he's out
there throwing stuff how long were you
there for how long were you in boston
just kind of studying this probably not
long a week
yeah like four or five days
and that was that was enough to give you
enough insight to take on this role and
and and have a certain seriousness to
your role and like to play and really
just take it seriously but also that's
where the comedy came in because if you
see the
you know the pilot we don't really have
a lot of comedy but i will tell you
those guys are funny and they have to be
in order to cope with what they're
seeing and what they're doing i mean
we're standing around a body and you
know one of the guys is like oh my god i
can't i can't get jimmy to eat his
broccoli and the other one's like oh
mine's fail in science and you know and
it's like you're standing there talking
about all this normal everyday stuff and
you're like
did you notice
i mean
it's a dead body or uh
[Laughter]
and that's what they do i mean they've
got a coat so it was and that's
kind of like i was like we gotta we
gotta make this funny i mean it's gotta
be and they're smart asses and they're
tough people and they're
you know it's yeah
that would be a great job by the way i
don't remember you ever posing
completely off topic posing nude for
allure magazine
well yeah because i'm covered like this
yeah so you're not naked
oh i'm naked
well they don't you don't see you naked
well you see enough of me naked what do
you see i didn't see anything
how did you not research this you know
to ask this question but you don't know
what the picture looks like touche i
didn't look because i thought it was
disrespectful because we know each other
may i ma'am may i may i have a look
after the podcast is over
michael don't act like you haven't tried
to get me naked for years oh my god
i love you i love her you know what's
funny is everybody who knows you always
says why don't you marry angie harmon
i'm like
because she's she's a she's the next
level up man i'm i'm a little she'd have
to look down
you know and she's probably taller than
me i don't how tall are you
five nine and a half now i'm taller than
him six foot
yeah you are yeah but we've determined
this when we were in person yeah by the
way on that note do you have uh do you
have people men hit on you quite often
do i what do you have men hit on you i
assume or women
uh yeah
actually
[Music]
well to be honest with you to be frank i
do i have people hitting on me here
yes i mean don't you i mean i i don't
know i'm oblivious to it so i'm always
like there's no way they're hitting on
me or there's no way they're flirting
with me there's no way i'm kind of like
that you know you said you had the
pretty girl syndrome where you're like
you don't think that you're pretty but
everybody thinks you're pretty but you
don't feel it i've always dealt with
that my whole life as well so i know how
you deal with that but how do you would
you go out with a commoner
you go out with someone who wasn't in
the acting business who wasn't you know
loaded who wasn't uh just a regular good
looking guy who was nice and you were
attracted to
yeah
you look everyone like i mean yeah
that's it's so funny that you bring that
up because
like we've this has really been a topic
as of late like
yeah i mean i would love to find my
person
yeah
i mean wouldn't you
yes yes
i would like to find my person
well and a lot of people you know i mean
you should hear the lists in this i mean
i just want a nice person
with a pulse
i'm good all right i mean i'm enough for
both of us all you got to do is sit
there and hang on and we're going to
have some fun don't worry about it by
the way we talk about like you know
people coming up to you a lot but did
you ever have any weird fans or anybody
who ever harassed you or anything like
that i remember you had someone
you have had that that's got to be the
worst especially for a woman right
yeah
as a matter of fact recently we just had
one um
and
actually a you know a girl who's now a
friend of mine i did not know her at the
time
um
i was sitting at the bar
and this guy comes over and he's totally
hammered
and just wasn't getting that
yeah you know because
we we as women we're we're taught like
we have to be nice and we have to be
respectful we have to be sweet and if
we're not we're a [ __ ] so you can't
tell some guy to go f himself because
you want to just hang with your
girlfriends and then you know also when
he's drunk and he's he's too stupid to
pick up on the police get the hell away
from me vibe who knows what he's going
to do when you tell him you know
to go after himself
yeah so anyway so
this couple on the other side of the bar
is that are we okay here yeah you're
great halo okay
this couple on the other side of the bar
i did not know
and she
like and the husband they were looking
at me and they're like are you okay
and i was like it's you know thanks so
much and this guy wouldn't stop so she
gets up and comes all the way over and
goes gets right in between us and does
the oh my god how are you i haven't seen
you in so long oh my god i've missed you
hugs my neck and i'm like i
love this woman and we must instantly be
friends helped you out and
yeah and did the whole thing it was like
come i got married come meet my husband
and so we went over there
and met them and just had
a blast with them and then this douche
comes around the bar and like starts up
again and starts giving me the stink eye
because
i didn't want anything to do with them
so the husband like was like you know
what let's go have a chat and like took
him over to the other side of the bar
and like had a chat with them on my
behalf and they they've never even met
me before and did the guy f off finally
yeah
geez people don't know when to just f
off
yeah i mean and he
like he kept like giving me dirty looks
like come on bro i mean
hey do you have mirrors in your house
let's just start there and b
what
i don't know maybe take an etiquette
class or some sort of you know
how to pick up women kind of thing
yeah because women love when you just
stare at them
yeah
let's see
in a menacing way yeah i mean if you
just give a little glance and you lock
eyes you get a smile hi you know
whatever a smile and then [ __ ] off and
then maybe 10 minutes later you kind of
look up and she's looking there's like
little things along the way
that's fine but like just
creepy stares man
this is called [ __ ] talking with angie
harmon i'm gonna ask you some fan
questions from my patrons uh you could
answer them as fast or slow as you want
leigh anne p the last few characters you
played have been law enforcement do you
enjoy this genre or would you consider
acting in different ones i mean you
obviously are because you're doing
lifetime stuff and you're doing other
things but um you love that
side of it don't you
i really do um and i'm blessed to have a
niche if you will niche if you will yeah
um but i will say my new one um barstow
the one that we're in pre-production now
i am so excited to play her
it's kind of like you know in
yellowstone you pull for the family even
though they're not the most moral and
ethically sound people and you know they
make decisions they're like
that was harsh
[Music]
barstow my character hazel is the same
way
and you find yourself pulling for her
and for these characters that she's with
you know because her main concern is
just protecting her daughter
and obviously i can you know touch into
a little bit of that personally
but um yeah i'm uh this is this is my
baby that i've been working on for
almost three years now what's it called
what's it called
barstow barstow and when's it come out
i don't we're in pre-productions right
now we're on um
script drafts things like that
um looking for a director we're supposed
to be sort of maybe putting an offer out
maybe tomorrow or monday for a director
and
oh i love it you go girl uh maya p what
types of projects do you hope to develop
with your new deal with lifetime
um there's three that i'm directing and
producing
one that i'm directing and starring in
um
and yeah that's i think i was so just
flattered by lifetime and
tanya um because she knew that i needed
to stay home for my girls and so she's
trying to make it as easy as possible
for me to do that
and continue to work
janine r what what charity or charities
do you support how can we help
oh my gosh i love you um
let's see um
um okay obviously unicef
um
the exodus chapter um
and basically anything you know that
tugs at your heartstrings or whatever
but um
what kind of tugs at mine
um is animals and uh child and human
trafficking you've got a big effing dog
yes
he's awesome benjamin's a giant and all
of mine are rescues
good mine too although one mine one of
them passed away a couple months ago boy
that was the hardest have you had to
deal with that before
um we just had to deal with the girl's
childhood dog
in doing that were they a mess
yeah
they were but then you know they kind of
i was surprised at how resilient they
were the adults were definitely a lot
more torn up
than the kids
well
this has been an absolute joy
i mean you know you are you have an
electric personality like i remember
meeting you and your ex and then we were
at
some place and then you guys came to my
80s party and i threw a big 80s party
and you came you're all decked out you
look fantastic i got to find those pic
do you still have the pictures
totally it's on my instagram really
yes oh i think it is
but it's i mean you're just
i don't know how i mean
you you don't have to be single is what
i'm saying there's a million guys
that would
marry you in a heartbeat anybody who's
ever met you who knows you or even
watches this interview will see that
you're full of life and
you know i just appreciate you coming on
here and talking to me i know you were a
little scared but didn't it did you have
fun
i i always have fun with you you know
that yeah i did and i am scared because
you know how private i am and you know
it's just like
i don't think yeah i don't think you got
i don't think you got too private i
think you said i'm not going to go there
and you just like hinted at little
things but you didn't you didn't go
anywhere but you gave enough to where
you know you could tell when things
you know what you were passionate about
and whatever i thought i thought it was
great ryan how did you feel about this
oh it was great
maybe you put your lips on the
microphone i thought it was great
and he was laughing a couple times you
made him laugh so that was good well
listen i love you
i love you and um i might have you do a
little
a little a little uh video of you saying
that you're going to be on the podcast
when it comes out and you'll post
something or whatever i absolutely will
i love you thank you for doing this i'll
be in touch and uh
i had a but i had a blast and i hope to
meet those girls sometimes maybe on
facetime or something you could
introduce me to them i'm telling you you
gotta come out here while they're in
school like you will literally just be
like this is unbelievable this [ __ ] show
is just nuts is charlotte's fun is it a
good town is it so fun oh my god we have
great food we have great bars everybody
like loves to have a good time and drink
i mean come on
i'm there i'll come out
i'll come out i will stay for a couple
days all right i'm serious too
that's okay all right
all right love your face
all right i love you too
i really enjoyed listening to angie
she's uh she's sweet as hell and she's
got a lot to talk about and uh you know
she's a single mom of you know three
daughters and uh that's that's a lot it
just seems like she's just the best
friend see my parents weren't best
friends with me they weren't my friends
at all they didn't want to be my friends
they didn't want to listen to me
but we don't need to get into that uh
thank you ange for for being on here i
really appreciate it i hope you enjoyed
it um again if you like the podcast
please subscribe write a review on
spotify apple go to youtube you could
watch it and then write a review it's
it's easy and if you like it maybe take
the time out to do it our handles if you
want to follow us on the instagram
facebook and twitter ryan uh inside to
be pod on twitter inside to be podcast
instagram and facebook that's exactly
right so do it and also if you want to
join patreon go to patreon.com inside of
you all my lovely patrons are there they
support the podcast so much and there's
a lot of perks where i send packages to
them and this and that and if you join
patreon i'll send you a message as soon
as i can as soon as i see it
uh also if you want to watch the band
january 29th we're playing you can watch
us virtually from your own home on the
tv or on your computer
just go to sunspin.com
and
you know you can find a link where we're
playing and
great prizes
zooms
you can go to stageit.com as well so
join us i really appreciate it if you if
you haven't heard us yet we play some
covers we play originals we're working
on a new album uh
it's a 45 minute
jam session it's just fun no i mean the
actual staging yeah so i think you'll
enjoy it
so i really do um so we have a lot of
great supporters and i you know i can
see your names as they scroll up and
i'll give you shout outs and all that
stuff it's fun to see oh look it's
newbie hey
uh scott from wisconsin scott 69
from i don't know but you see their
handle and you just you know whatever
also the inside of you online store has
a bunch of great stuff um
lexmas scripts signed by me uh
smallville lunch boxes tumblers inside
of you just a bunch of stuff so go to
the inside you online store get those
while they last
and uh i want to read off the top
patrons because
that's what we do here on the show that
is what we do these are people who uh
give back to the show in more
more ways than one and really go above
and beyond expectations so it's pretty
crazy i can't wait to um
uh announce some good news oh but i
can't do it yet because we you know
i think we're gonna do it in the trades
or you know something we're gonna
announce it so i'm not sure i should
just blurb it out but it's something
really cool so keep listening for that
and uh here we go
here we freaking go these are the top
patrons here we go nancy d leah s sarah
v little lisa yukiko jill
e brian h nico p robert b jason
w
kristen k amelia oh allison l raj c cjp
jennifer n stacy l jen s jamal f janelle
b adrian m mike e eldon sopremo 99 moore
ramira santiago m chad w
leanne p
janine r maya
belinda n chris h dave h spider-man
chase
sheila
g correct this is just random ryan i'm
just doing a random ryan i'm picking it
up brad
brad d ray h tabitha t tom n liliana a
michelle k
talia m betsy d laura l chad l rochelle
nathan e marion meg k trav l dan n big
stevie w angel m
rhiannon c corey k super sam coleman g
dev
nixon tev nixon is correct you tired
ryan no what i'm good michelle a jeremy
c tony cody r sebastian k gavin nader
that's correct gabinator david c john b
brandy d yvore camille s the c
joey m willie f christina e adelaide n
omari lena n eugene and leah chris p
nikki g corey patricia maria n
heather l jake b bobbitt bob it's a new
one bobbitt bobbitt
bobbitt ed a twist a bell a no ed a a
bell f a bell sorry about that abell f
and tony g
uh actually abell had a question for one
of my last guests which which will air
soon
see if you're a patron you get to ask
questions sometimes so
it's pretty neat anything you want to
tell me ryan was it was a bell's
question uh i was wondering if that for
all these years that you'd like to meet
what
adele oh no i said abel huh or is it
able maybe her name is abel isn't canaan
i think it's able abel that's able it's
able did i say a bell yeah okay well
abel f i apologize it's able you're able
you're able f
able af
jesus idiots we're just idiots christ
thanks for listening uh to us babel here
i appreciate it uh continue to listen to
the podcast we love you from uh the
hollywood hills in california i'm
michael rosenbaum i've been ryan taylor
and a little wave to the camera we love
you guys thanks for listening have a
great week be good to yourselves and
i'll see you very soon
[Music]